you wanted to see me no lemon
I did Oh bye don't enjoy look I never
should have interfered with them
whatever this is work husband / uncle
coworkers / little brother right well
she's not ready to move on it's true
I'm wearing a duane reade bag is
underwear today oh right and for
whatever reason he needs you to it's a
symbiotic relationship I'm a mighty
great white shark lemon and you are a
Remora clinging to me with your suction
cup head I'll give you a free ride and
in exchange you eat my parasites
betcha he breeds batches she sews better
they made me I'll closet of clothes
lemon what tragedy happened in your life
and you insist upon punishing yourself
with all this mediocrity well cuz I'm
eating a turkey sub your turkey sub your
clothes the fact that a woman of your
resources and position lives like some
boxcar hobo or maybe it's the fact that
what I'm saying all this you have a
piece of lettuce stuck in your hair this
is the unlisted number of stone the most
exclusive restaurant in the city
currently I think it's time that you
start enjoying some of the finer things
in life completely unsolicited and
inappropriate I will only accept it
because I love food do you know why Jack
Welsh is the greatest leader since the
Pharaohs because he didn't only involve
himself in our work lives but our
personal lives as well he introduced us
to the finest booze the most restrictive
country clubs he gave us the names of
the most discreet private investigators
to spy on our ex-wives
he held our hands during our triumphs
and our Senate hearings I want to hold
your hand lemon Yanks this is a perfect
example you have a million dollar view
and you refuse to acknowledge though
there's a whole world out there oh my
there appears to be a gentleman making
passionate penguin love to himself yeah
I know that's why I closed the blinds in
the first place
right in his office huh lemon I'd like
to think of myself as a winner I like to
surround myself with winners I see
potential in you let me be your jack
roush let me be your mentor no thank you
that is unfortunate you've got to admire
his persistence their stamina though
am I wrong or is he in the middle of a
staff meeting maybe you should be his
mentor obviously he doesn't need one
he's got it all figured out hey do you
have a neck pillow I blew my nup and now
it smells like my mouth I never sleep on
planes I don't want to get in septic are
you going somewhere
Carol has a flight to raleigh-durham so
I'm going with him and we're gonna drive
out and spend a few days at an inn at
nags head you're going to nags head
isn't that redundant
[Music]
you're going to Nags it isn't that
redundant you will hand me an envelope
predicting my joke about nags head that
is solid Avery and I are also having a
little romantic weekend together before
the baby comes we're going to Toronto
for the g8 economic summit is going to
be very erotic look at us being all
adulty I packed underwear that isn't
great isn't it nice dating someone you
have so much in common with like you
Avery is a type a nut job and of course
you and Carol share your trademark
stubbornness
we're not stubborn were principled have
a nice trip lemon break out those
underpass but be careful dating yourself
is a double-edged sword
it means you also share the same flaws
well that would only be a problem if I
had any flaws not only as your fly open
there's a pencil sticking out of it good
day to you sir
[Music]
good morning how's the happy couple
today well it's no surprise we're
sitting here you two have always thrown
off that will they or won't they in vile
hoot to watch your courtship okey-dokey
now when two employees get married it is
my job to make sure that the employee is
not receiving favoritism from his or her
boss favoritism really he's trying to
cancel my show uh-huh and what about
your little announcement last night do
you know how many fires I had to put out
this morning because of you what's that
voice it is my imitation of Joo
Barrymore's impression of that crazy
lady let's keep this meeting short our
marriage is a technicality and it will
be remedied also in order for there to
be favoritism we'd have to actually
still be friends all righty let's just
dive on in does the employee spend in an
ordinate amount of time in the employers
office compared to other employees oh
yes I suppose but only because Miss
lemon isn't capable of doing anything on
her own oh please
half the time when I go up there it's to
help you choose the tie and they're all
red or blue you know where I come from
if you have more than two colors on a
tie and these you're looking for a
certain kind of bar are all work take
conversations business-related or do
personal issues often dominate
discussion including but not limited to
mothers diarrhea having babies problems
in the bedroom neckties food issues foot
disorders having it all okay yes in the
past we have advised each other for
instance Jack taught me not to wear tan
slacks with a tan turtleneck I thought
it looked nice but he rightly pointed
out that it made me look like a giant
condom and lemon is the only one of my
subordinates who's not afraid to warn me
when I'm being too authoritative or
handsome or when you have eye boogers
have you spent time with each other's
families have you attended special
events together such as class reunions
birthday or holiday celebrations
weddings or extended car trips are you
each other's emergency contacts
do you ever drink together at work
perhaps while summarizing what you've
learned over the day or week have you
shared intimate details of your fears
hopes and dreams both personal and
professional is this the longest and
perhaps most meaningful relationship in
your life
do you often find yourself thinking the
same thing and then saying it at the
exact same time I apologize I never
should have tried to blackmail you I'll
sign the papers and I shouldn't have
threatened your show I'll leave that to
the parental decency groups and I'll
back off on the budget dan the bud
mitzvos okay now we're gonna do word
association foreplay we're done waitress
laughs try to walk like a woman I mean
your fly's open jack that way after the
crash they'll be like I did see him
drinking Oh God that idiot what did he
do
yeah that's what they'll say
no no don't worry lemon there is no
cause for alarm you are watching my
video suicide no huh oh my god
try not to blame yourself how were you
to know that I was in such a dark place
that the smallest thing for example a
close friend's refusal to reconcile
would be the final straw he killed
himself because of me this is like what
happened with my gynecologist all over
again I do have a parting gift for you
lemon his phone I can track his phone go
to youtube and search Hamlet the mini
pig goes downstairs Hamlet the mini pig
no phone first I'll watch the pig video
in the cab hello lemon
that was the idea it was extreme but
necessary I didn't want to be just
another person on your grudge list
gee which reminds me why am I still
seeing new top chefs with that bold
salad ruiner I had 10 hours to force you
to confront the soul-crushing horror of
a life without me I didn't lie when I
said I was going away I'm off to
discover what makes me happy I have to
find my bliss which for once is not an
acronym for beautiful ladies and short
shorts how long will you be gone as long
as it takes to figure out what's next
although I've only been on this boat a
minute I've already realized two things
about myself one I could totally be a
professional boat model and two I do
know one thing that has made me happy in
these last seven years lemon there is a
word a once special word that's been
tragically co-opted by the romance
industrial complex and I would hate to
use it here and have you think that I'm
suggesting any kind of romantic
sentiment let alone an invitation to
scale bone mountain it's a word that
comes to us by way of the old high
german luba from the latin loo bear a
meaning to be pleasing so I'm going to
use this word to describe how I feel
about you in the way that our
anglo-saxon forefathers would have you
in reference to say a hot bowl of bear
meat your enemy's skull split I love you
too jack
you